[Music]
many people are saying this is the that
the experiment the election we're having
right now is the dirtiest election in
history now
many people know if you read up on
American history there were a lot of
election there are some plenty sleazy
things happened going back to the
founding fathers yeah I mean Thomas
Jefferson allies calling John Adams
hermaphrodite yeah John Quincy Adams
it's true this is John Quincy Adams his
allies going after Andrew Jackson's wife
suggesting she was a bigamist yes which
she might have been yeah and know it he
took that very Pamina he was she died
she died and he said that the reason she
died was that she was so ashamed of this
scurrilous attack on her so this country
has been there before but what a PC
Annalise
it's the out it's the it's the people
behind the president yeah or the
candidate who were doing it not John
Quincy Adams tweeting your wife's a
bigamist yeah sad right okay yeah talk
about that he's a fellow scholar of a
ambach Trump and Trump ammeter yeah his
special way of writing tweets
yes declarative statement declarative
statement adjective yeah his own kind of
haiku when you think it's a little full
well so here's my here's my question in
this campaign we have candidates leading
Republican candidates until Rubio
dropped out who were sort of mocking
each other for penis size that feels
like sort of yeah well okay but this
feels like a new does it feel to you
like we've hit a new low below the belt
as it were it look these two can't
believe you went there
did he really just make that joke Marco
Rubio did make the the reference yeah
about small hands and what it means
Marco Rubio's kind of felt like he
decided to join Trump down in the gutter
and then I get he subsequently regretted
it and Donald Trump assured America at
the next debate I there's no problem
down there I guarantee it right which
was what I said to women at bars for
years it has the it has a chilling
effect on them and that day and the
guarantee was just as valuable yeah
exactly any guy that walks around saying
no problem down there ladies no problem
so what's your name yeah lead with that
do you think Trump will be the nominee I
do I do think he'll be the nominee I've
been saying since last fall I don't see
any way that the Republicans who are
running against him can stop him yeah
and he has been a force he has a
dedicated and devoted group of
supporters 35 to 45 percent depending on
the state and there is almost nothing he
can do that will only it's almost I
think there is nothing Trump can say big
word or do and those people will not
think oh it's been twisted by the media
or that's just trumping Trump
leave us alone we've met he himself has
said I could shoot somebody on Fifth
Avenue and they would still support me
right he said that right and then weeks
later some woman said I would he could
shoot somebody in the street and I would
vote for him right has this mesmerizing
persuasion quality okay leads us to the
next question
we could have conventions in in our
lifetime have been pretty stage-managed
yeah boring Affairs we all know what's
going to happen and we pretend that
we're going to see something exciting
happen we could actually have a
contested convention in Cleveland and I
have to admit it's kind of exciting it's
the it's the old guard Republican Party
trying to get control I mean that would
be wouldn't it be as a journalist
wouldn't you be excited it would be
exciting it would be exciting to cover
you might remember I think it was 2004
that conventions were so boring I was a
TV
news at the time Ted Koppel and
Nightline just left they said this is
bogus these are these are just
infomercials this would actually be an
actual convention and thankfully you
noted the support the petition on
change.org thousands of people saying
that Republicans should be able to bring
guns guns so that thankfully the US
Secret Service has said no because
otherwise I was I was planning on
covering the Cleveland Convention from
Cincinnati yeah you don't want to be
there in Ohio
you